[MUSIC PLAYING]
MJ: Keyon Dooling
here at Google to talk
about his personal
experience with mental health
what-- and then what the
NBA is doing because he is
a former NBA basketball player.
So a little bit about Keyon,
who we are very lucky to
have with us today.
He was born in Florida and
attended the University
of Missouri, where he was the
10th overall pick in the NBA
draft in 2000.
Definitely good draft year.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah.
Solid.
MJ: He played for
seven NBA teams,
so he knows a lot about
the NBA, including
the, Clippers which are
obviously based here in LA,
and the Celtics, who are still
in the playoffs right now.
Go Celtics.
And now he is currently serving
in the NBA Players Association
as a player rep.
He also is an author,
a motivational speaker,
and the founder--
the co-founder of the Respect
Foundation with his wife,
and he's doing a lot of work
in the mental health awareness
community.
So we are very lucky
to have him here.
So thank you for being here.
KEYON DOOLING: MJ, thank you
for that kind introduction.
MJ: So just to get
started, I thought
it would be useful for the
group to hear a little bit more
about your personal background
and why mental health
is so important to you.
KEYON DOOLING: So I
grew up in a little town
called Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
And I grew up in an era
where we knew our neighbors.
We could go and knock on the
door and borrow some sugar.
But also during that time
in the '80s crack hit.
And so I saw my community
go from being this united
community where you
could go and borrow sugar
and you knew all the neighbors
to really like a war zone.
And so my upbringing
was awesome.
I come from a
two-parent household.
My father worked for himself.
We had a florist, so we
had a family business.
And he also used to skycap
at Eastern Airlines for my 80
babies.
And my mother was an educator
for a great part of her life.
She was a teacher,
and during the 80s,
she switched careers to go
as a drug counselor because
of the epidemic.
It hit our family.
It hit our neighborhood.
And so she was
passionate about it,
and she became a drug
treatment counselor.
And so that's a little
bit of background.
I'm the youngest of four, and
that's a little bit about me.
MJ: Cool.
So what is your personal
experience with mental health?
Why are you spending
your time now
that you don't have much free
time promoting this awareness
work?
KEYON DOOLING: So I was forced
to deal with my mental health
issues.
I went through a few
tragedies as a child.
At the heart of
it, I was sexually
abused when I was
seven years old,
and I had never really
dealt with that.
I took that into my adulthood.
And so in my twelfth
year in the NBA,
I was doing some trips--
some charity work in Seattle,
Washington, and I was
using the restroom
and a guy felt on me while
I was in the restroom.
And it triggered me.
And so all these things that
I had pretty much pushed down,
compressed I was going to lock
the door and throw away the key
and not ever have to deal with
some of those experiences,
but in that moment
I got triggered.
And that barrier, that block
that I put up in my mind
to block it out
came tumbling down,
and I was forced to deal with
this intensed, intensed battle
with PTSD.
And so in doing my work
and in overcoming that
is when I became a
mental health advocate.
And I felt like I found
a recipe for healing.
And I'm vulnerable enough
to share that experience
so that others may benefit
from it so that they
don't have to hit rock bottom
in order to build themselves up.
MJ: It's so brave of you for
sharing that story as well.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
MJ: And what you just
mentioned is something
that you've spoken about
publicly in the past.
KEYON DOOLING: Sure.
MJ: And one question that I've
had in just getting to know you
a little bit is that was
that the first time that you
acknowledged that
you did have PTSD?
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah.
Yeah.
For me, the symptoms of
being abused as a child
and seeing gunshots and
things like that as a child,
it didn't really--
I'd never allowed
myself to feel it.
The way it would come
out is with my behaviors
and in my emotions.
And so I suffered from anxiety
in my childhood quite a bit.
And I took that into adulthood.
That's one of the ways
that it manifested.
I had anger issues at
different points in my life.
I think it made me
overcompensate and become more
macho because when something
happens to you as a child,
you build up these walls.
Another thing in my behavior is
being promiscuous early in life
is something that
I had to overcome.
But PTSD didn't manifest until
I was triggered at 32 years old.
So I was able to manage
the anxiety, self-care,
but when I got triggered, those
little techniques that I had,
they were out of the
door because that
was too powerful for those
little mild techniques
to work on.
MJ: So can you talk
a little bit more
about how you actually
went about confronting
that you did have
PTSD, especially being
an NBA athlete at that time.
This is now six years
ago, and there--
today luckily there are
athletes coming out--
Kevin Love and DeMar DeRozan
publicly about their own
experiences.
But at the time,
you were probably
the first one to really be--
to openly discuss it.
So can you talk
about what barriers
you had to overcome in terms
of addressing that stigma
and still being able to
successfully play in the NBA?
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah, so I
would say the first thing
the stigma is that
I was embarrassed.
I was ashamed because my abuse
came at the hands of a man.
I was seven years old.
He was about 14, 15
years old at that time.
I was really ashamed about that,
really embarrassed about that.
So I decided at a very
early age that I just
wouldn't tell anybody.
And so I just really wanted to--
how do I say it?
When you're young,
you don't understand.
It was no examples of
where to go to heal.
When I was looking
around for examples
of men who had been
through some of the things
that I had to overcome, I
didn't see a lot of examples.
And so I knew I wanted to
be an example for people
once I built myself up.
But, yeah, it was
a tough situation.
I'm actually glad that
I went through it,
that I got triggered,
that I had to battle PTSD
because if I had not
I would probably still
have some of the same behaviors.
My anxiety would still
probably be through the roof.
So it forced me to do my work.
But what I want to
tell everybody else
is that you don't have to
be forced to do your work.
You can actually take the
step to start doing your work
to start building yourself up.
And I always say that
the first step of healing
is really embracing the
pain in the first place.
And that's the first step.
MJ: Exactly and now you are the
example for a lot of people, so
hopefully just you being
open about your experience
and getting help and what
that has done for you
will help others in
similar situations
be able to take that first
step without that trigger.
KEYON DOOLING: Absolutely
because when you get triggered,
it's a very vulnerable time.
And you don't know how
you'll react to that trigger.
So if I would have gone out
and gotten help actively,
I probably would have never
had to deal with PTSD.
I probably would have
been able to catch
it, learn the tools
and the techniques
to be able to manage it.
But for me, I just didn't
embrace mental health.
I didn't know what
it looked like.
I didn't see many examples
of people going to therapy.
And so-- I also
was very successful
at every intersection in life
I had like to bust through
and break through and become.
And a lot of times when
you're successful when you're
climbing, you don't
get to process
what you've experienced,
especially as athletes.
We don't necessarily get
to process what we've seen,
what we've been through,
what we've encountered,
the punishment that we
put our bodies through,
and so we internalize
our pain, our issues.
We mask it.
And so I don't want
to do that anymore.
I felt like in order
for me and my family
to get to the next
level, I had to heal.
I feel like I ran
away from basketball.
I didn't play with
PTSD because I didn't
think I was strong enough.
I didn't know what
I was experiencing,
so I decided to retire from
the NBA to get myself healthy.
MJ: And that's the most
important thing for sure.
So when you did confront
that you were experiencing
PTSD, what are some of the
things that did help you
get back to a healthy place.
KEYON DOOLING:
[EXHALES DEEPLY] Well,
I don't think it was one
thing that helps me on a daily
basis--
I say it in the present tense
because I'm still healing.
And I believe like I'll be
healing the rest of my life.
And so I had to
learn these tools
to be able to manage all
these different emotions.
As men a lot of
times we can resonate
with like pleasure and anger.
And there's so many emotions
in between that and enduring
the therapy process and in going
through the healing process,
I was able to
identify and recognize
all these emotions that as a man
I never allowed myself to feel.
Perfect example, as
men a lot of times
we're told to shut up,
suck it up, be tough
when the first natural language
that we speak is a cry.
If you're not crying,
they'll smack you on the butt
and make sure you cry
because that's normal.
We have these tear ducts
that produce water that
allows us to cry but we are--
we're told a lot of times
as men to suck it up.
And so for me, I
wanted to make sure
that I understood my emotions,
I understood my triggers,
I understood what I'm
grappling against so
that I can have the best
recipe, the best tools, the best
resources to be able
to take care of myself,
not just for a short time
but over the course of time,
over the course of my life
and then also generationally.
I think a lot of times
families, we pass down
negative stigmas to our kids.
And so in regards
to mental health,
the way that it's
talked about, a shrink,
a head doctor, you're crazy, all
these different negative words
that we associate
with mental health.
And if we just shift that up,
if we shifted a little bit
and have the right
word magic around it,
we could really
de-stigmatize mental health
and really treat it
for what it's worth.
MJ: Yeah.
You made a great point in
just the conversation with men
specifically with
the stigma attached.
And I think every different
group, whether it's your family
or where you're from or the
type of job that you're in,
has a slightly different
stigma attached to it.
And that's obviously why
these types of events
are so critical in helping
us all come together
to open up this dialogue
because we're all
experiencing different
types of mental health.
So can you-- going back to
your support system, which
did allow you to access
treatment without saying Keyon,
suck it up.
You're a man.
Can you talk a little bit
about your support system
through this experience
and what types of things
they did that were helpful.
There are a lot of people
here and probably watching
that are either
experiencing PTSD themselves
or have friends,
family, coworkers
who are, so how can we
be supported and support
each other?
KEYON DOOLING: I would say
the first thing is my family.
My family really
supported me through what
I was going through.
They knew I was going
through something.
We just didn't know what it was.
We didn't understand
what PTSD was,
but they knew something
was going on with me.
And they didn't run away.
They didn't hide.
They leaned in,
and they made sure
that I got the right resources.
They made sure that they
protected me around that.
And another thing,
a lot of times,
we'll internalize
things because we
don't think people
will understand
or our infrastructure
is not there
to help us, love us, support us,
and I was so wrong about that.
The Boston Celtics,
man, were there for me.
Danny Ainge, Doc Rivers,
Rajon Rondo, Avery Bradley,
all of my teammates,
they were there for me.
And a lot of times we think we
were struggling with something,
we're in it by ourselves.
And what I learned
through this process
is that when I needed my
village to be there for me,
that village was
there for me, and I'm
so thankful and so grateful
for all the resources
that the NBA and the Players
Association had in place
because that played a
big part in my healing.
All the love and support that I
got from my Celtics family, all
the love and support that
I got from my friends,
and that combination
allowed me to give myself
permission to heal.
MJ: So do you--
going back to your
teammates, do you still
keep in touch with them?
KEYON DOOLING: Absolutely.
I mean, not everybody.
Everybody is so busy, and
those guys, a lot of them
are still playing
and being excellent.
But, yeah, I have great
relationships with my friends.
Now also I did lose some
friends in this process.
Mental health is so
misunderstood that people
will tar and feather you.
They'll isolate you,
and they'll make you
feel like you have an issue.
And they might not be
comfortable with that.
But what I'll say is
if I have a knee issue,
I'm going to try and
go to the best surgeon
to get it repaired.
If I have an issue
with my teeth,
I'm going to go to the best
dentist to get it prepared .
But where do you go when
your heart and your head
is out of whack
or you're feeling
emotional about something?
Where do you go?
And for years I would go
to maybe a glass of wine
or try and distract
myself another way.
But therapy to me was a place
where I really, really got
a lot of healing.
I spent four days in
a mental institution.
And for me I didn't
get healing there,
but I got the epiphany there
that I needed to do my work.
So that-- I appreciate that
experience for that alone.
But the therapy process--
in three weeks of therapy,
I was able to dump off
about 25 years of baggage
that I had been holding onto,
that I had never processed,
allowed myself to feel
that I was still carrying.
And every time I
would go to therapy
and I would drop off
some of this baggage,
I would feel a little
lighter when I came out.
And then I would go back
the next wait-- the next day
and I would drop off
some of that baggage
and I would feel
a little lighter.
And it wasn't just the
cathartic experience
of dropping off the baggage,
but it was the tools that I
was able to get from
my therapist to be
able to manage that emotion--
to be able to
identify that emotion.
And so I start more--
maturing more emotionally.
It's called emotional maturity.
And I'm so thankful that through
the therapy process that I
learned how to process things.
MJ: Yes, therapy is
one of the best things
that we can do to
maintain our mental health
and to improve it.
But you mentioned the tools
that your therapist gave you.
Can you talk a little bit
about any specific tools
that have helped you
maintain on a daily basis?
KEYON DOOLING: Absolutely
because the same plan
that I got from my
therapist six years ago
is the same plan that I'm
working with a few tweaks
here and there.
But I take a holistic approach.
I believe in the mental,
the physical, the spiritual,
and the emotional
part of health--
holistic health.
And so the first
place that I started
was in my spiritual experience,
praying, talking to the Lord
and just getting that
connection point.
The second thing that
I did from there--
excuse me, from getting my
prayer life together and making
sure that I talk with God
and consulted with him first.
But the next thing
I did was therapy.
Therapy to me was the
biggest gateway for healing.
It was unbelievable what
I was able to accomplish
in the therapy
process, what I was
able to learn
about myself, where
I was able to trace some of
the origins of my behavior
and my trauma.
And it's very difficult.
The most difficult thing
about therapy is going,
taking that first step.
Once I got in there, it was
just a very awesome experience.
And then physical .
I'm an athlete, and so I believe
that in all the mind, body,
spirit, it all works together.
And so I still have
a physical routine
that I do five,
six times a week.
I implemented yoga into that.
I go get treatment on my body.
I have two degenerative hips.
And so I do a lot of things
to make myself feel good.
I get massages.
I learned about essential oils.
I'm on no prescription drugs.
But I take a lot
of natural things.
I like herbs, and I
like essential oils.
And I like different things like
that, chamomile tea and things
that help me relax.
And so I had to learn how to--
I had to learn my system.
And it's not for everyone.
I think everybody has-- it's
no blueprint for success.
There's many
blueprints for success,
and you have to find out what
your interests are, where
your pride is and where your--
excuse me, where your prizes
are in regards to health.
And that's what I did.
I explored it.
I still explore it.
I still get therapy.
I still work out.
I still try and eat
right and I just try--
if I have an off day,
I don't internalize it.
I talk about it.
I talk about it
with my therapist.
I talk about it with my family.
We've created an environment in
my family where it's OK for us
to talk about mental health.
And so we have
those discussions,
and we embrace it
totally as a family.
MJ: I love your phrase
learn your system.
I think, again, what
you were mentioning
earlier for so long mental
health was this taboo thing.
It wasn't talked about,
and it was thought of--
thought to be
completely separate
of our physical health.
But in reality, the more
research that comes out,
the more we understand that
everything is intertwined,
and learning your system
is a great way to put it.
There will be no one
solution that fits everyone
because we are all different
and unique, and that's awesome.
But it's a lot about
knowing yourself and finding
those ways that you can maintain
both aspects of your health.
KEYON DOOLING: No, absolutely.
Sometimes a video game--
playing the video game
could help relax me.
Sometimes going for a nice
little walk can help relax me.
I think everybody
has to find out
their interests, what makes--
what allows them to get
to their happy place
and be able to go
back to those places.
Also the power of
visualization, sometimes I
can't go back to
Bahamas physically,
but I can close my eyes
and visualize that view
and [INHALES] suck up that
air and smell that scent
and it will help.
And I think sometimes
that mind-body experience
needs to be highlighted.
Sometimes we have-- as
kids, we can imagine things.
I remember going to
the park as a kid,
and it would be no scoreboard
no crowd out there.
But I'll be having my
eyes closed and Dooling
for the game--
3, 2, 1, and the
crowd goes crazy.
[IMITATES CROWD NOISE] Open
my eyes, nobody's there,
but in that vision,
it was real to me.
And a lot of times
with our healing,
we have to sometimes
visualize ourselves as healthy
and then wake up and then take
the necessary steps to find
that health.
But, yeah, the power of
visualization I think
is awesome, too.
MJ: Luckily, we're not
too far from the beach
so you don't have to visualize
the Bahamas we're only
a couple away--
a couple of blocks
away from Venice Beach.
KEYON DOOLING: I
know that's right.
You know what.
I got some exercise
clothes out there.
I might have to hit Muscle
Beach up, minus the muscles.
MJ: Gold's Gym is right outside.
I could talk about your
story all day long.
It's extremely powerful
and brave of you
to share that with
all of us, but I
want to spend some time
to talk about the work
that you're doing now and
in the awareness space.
KEYON DOOLING: Please.
MJ: To start off, what made you
take this step from treating
yourself and making
sure that you're healthy
and make the decision that it's
important for you to share this
and why is it important to
take work on this awareness?
KEYON DOOLING: So I got to
give my wife some credit.
When I was going through
my break down situation,
I just didn't want to share.
I didn't want to tell anybody.
I just wanted to heal,
get my individual healing,
and then ease back into life.
But she challenged me.
She said, hey, you've gone
through this for a reason.
And there are so many people who
are going through what you're
going through, and they
might not have the resources
that you have.
They might not have
the access to therapy
and the right health care and
all those different things.
And so you got to
help people with this.
And so I'm so glad she
challenged me because also
as a man because I was abused at
the hands of another young man,
hey, man, I was
ashamed about that.
And the fact that
she didn't judge me
and that she didn't look
down on me for going
through what I went through--
the only thing she
was mad about is
that I didn't tell
her because she
could have helped me
heal along the way
and that I kept from her.
And so yeah that gave me enough
courage to be able to go out
and do this work
that I'm doing now.
I believe the biggest
room in all of our houses,
in all of our lives is
the room for improvement.
The biggest room in our house
is the room for improvement.
And I want to share what I
learned through my processes
with the masses so that
they can get healing.
It's so many people
who are walking
around right now with a
big smile on their face,
but they might be
suffering with anxiety.
It's so many people
who might be walking
around looking
gorgeous, and they might
be suffering with depression.
There's so many people who
are one step away from getting
triggered to having
a battle with PTSD,
but they might not even
know their triggers.
And so I want to be a
mirror to each person
so that they can find
healing for themselves
through looking at the way
that I attacked this healing
process.
It was not easy.
There were some days there
was some parts of myself
that I didn't like to see
when I peeled back some
of those layers in the onion.
But in doing that, that's where
the accountability comes in.
That's where the growth
opportunities come in.
And so I would encourage
anybody right now
if you're grappling
with something,
if you don't even know
why you have anxiety
or why you're angry or
why you're isolating,
man, I really want
to challenge you
that the first step to
healing is embracing the pain.
And a lot of times when
you embrace the pain,
you'll find power in that.
You'll find purpose in that.
And then you'll be able
to help other people who
might be grappling or going
through the same thing
that you're experiencing.
MJ: Yeah, exactly again,
none of us are alone in this.
We're all experiencing--
we all have mental health
to deal with.
So it's sometimes a
very powerful thing
is just asking someone
how are they doing.
KEYON DOOLING: No doubt.
MJ: So do you want to
talk a little bit more
about your foundation?
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah, let's talk
about the Respect Foundation.
So the Respect
Foundation is a 501c3.
We believe that we can help
eliminate sexual abuse.
We believe that we can raise
awareness around mental health.
I believe the number are 1
out of every 4 young ladies,
1 out of every 6 young men
are abused in this country
before the age--
as children.
And there's about
30% that are like me
who don't talk about it.
And so I learned in doing
my research in doing
this work that if
we equip our kids
and if we equip people
with the knowledge,
they can help prevent
some of these things.
And what I mean is
like teaching kids,
hey, what is a healthy touch?
What is healthy dialogue?
Hey, if something
going on in your life,
where do you share that with?
Just really equipping
kids and empowering
them to not be silent.
I think a lot of times we're
told within families shut up.
What happens in this
house, stays in this house.
It never happened.
Don't tell anybody our business.
And what happens is
these cycles continue,
not only in our families
but in our safe havens,
in schools, in churches,
in all these places
where it should be safe havens.
So I wanted to make
sure that I reached out
and I touched kids through
my I Am Respect Tour.
I bring music.
I bring artwork.
I bring spoken
word entertainment.
I bring all these
different elements
to distract you a little
bit so that we can give you
a good positive message and
give you some great tools
to be able to help
your family maybe
prevent getting abused one day.
And if you have been abused,
what healing looks like.
How does healing look for you?
What's the process?
What's the steps to heal?
And so we wanted to be a
resource with our 501c3,
the Respect Foundation.
MJ: Yes.
Amazing.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
MJ: In all of the different
communities that you've
gone to, have you seen major
differences in the types
of stigma that exist amongst
different communities
across the country?
KEYON DOOLING: I
think mental health is
it's a lot of negative
stigmas across--
I don't think it's
a cultural thing.
I think that
there's room to grow
for every culture
around mental health.
But I'll speak
from my experience
as a member of the
Black community.
I think that less than 6%
of black men get therapy.
It's a crazy number like that.
Less than 6% of us get therapy.
And I believe we come
from some of the most
traumatic experiences
in this country.
And I believe that
there is so much
room for healing if
we start embracing
our mental health the
way that we have embraced
our physical health and
if we start really locking
in and diving in and trying
to understand our experience,
understand what we went through,
understand what makes us hurt,
I think it's a great opportunity
for us to grow and get better
and do a better job
of just fighting
that negative stigma
of mental health.
So, yeah, I think there's room
to grow for every culture.
And I'm so glad and I'm
a part of this dialogue
because just because I'm from--
I'm a black man from
the black community,
my skills are transferable.
I've lived in the suburbs
a great part of my life.
And I know that there
are certain issues that
are doesn't matter if you're
in the hood or the suburbs,
an issue is an issue.
I tell my kids all the time
because they didn't grow up
in a traumatic environment
the way that I did,
I'm not going to
minimize their experience
because that is real to them.
And sharing is caring.
As long as we show compassion
and we share these tools
that we learn, it's
transferable no matter
what culture you're from.
MJ: Exactly.
And in your work
with the foundation,
you're obviously connecting
childhood sexual abuse
with mental health.
KEYON DOOLING: Right.
MJ: How do you see those
two things working together?
What's the relationship
between them?
KEYON DOOLING: Well, I
think they go hand in hand
because when you've
gone through trauma,
there's going to be some mental
health issues that come along
with that.
They say the top four
symptoms for somebody
who's been abused, whether
it's physical abuse,
mental abuse, sexual abuse,
or whatever, abuse in general,
is anxiety, which I
suffer from, depression,
which at one point in my
life I've experienced,
sexual dysfunction, and PTSD.
And at some point
in my life, I have
struggled with all of
those different things
at different moments in my life.
And so it's not just
about the mental health.
It's about how do I
get better from it.
I think some people get stuck
at just saying, hey, I have a--
I'm having an emotional
issue, and they choose
to not do anything about it.
I want encourage people
to activate their faith,
activate their resources
because healing awaits you.
It's right there.
You just have to take
it, and the hardest part
is getting up and taking that
first step and pursuing it.
MJ: And everything
that you're doing
is making it easier
for people to do that.
KEYON DOOLING: I'm trying, MJ.
I'm trying.
MJ: You're sharing
your own story.
You're working with
your foundation.
And you're also working with
the NBA Players Association.
KEYON DOOLING: That's correct.
MJ: And they-- the
NBA's been very active
in the mental health
dialogue this season.
Kevin Love has come out and
openly about a panic attack
he had during a game.
DeMar DeRozan has talked
about his depression.
Obviously, you were
recently featured
in several articles in May.
We had a celebrity amongst
us everyone in case
you didn't know.
KEYON DOOLING: I
don't know about that.
MJ: So can you talk a little--
and they just also during
the Western Conference
finals had a commercial
about mental health.
KEYON DOOLING: Yes.
MJ: That featured both Kevin
Love and DeMar DeRozan,
which brought tears
of joy to my eyes
to see that the message
is being that broadly.
KEYON DOOLING: It's happening.
MJ: Yes.
MJ: So can you share
a little bit more
about what the NBA is
doing and potentially how--
when you were a player
how you were supported
and how that has evolved over
the last five, six years?
KEYON DOOLING: So
the latest thing
that we've done at the
NBA Players Association
is we're building this program
called the Mental Wellness
Program.
I'm an advisor for the program.
And basically we're putting
the resources in place
all across the country where
guys can get their healing
outside of just the team
concept because a lot of times
in athletics it could be
a conflict of interest.
If you having-- if
you're grappling
with an emotional
issue, you may not
want to go to the team doctor
because they could potentially
hold that against you.
So we wanted to create
something that was set aside
that players could truly
get their healing in a way
where it would be
confidential and healthy.
We just really want to meet
our guys where they are.
Our guys are young.
They're talented.
They're famous.
They have wealth.
And along with that,
it's a whole host
of issues that come along
with the pressures of being
as excellent as they are.
So we want to make
sure that just
like we have the best
trainers and we have the best
medical doctors and we have the
best coaches and the best GMs,
we want to make sure
also that we have
the best resources for their
mental health and emotional
health.
And I'm so glad to
be a part of that.
MJ: Yeah, it's amazing.
When you first had
this idea, what--
how is it received by everyone
else in the organization?
Was there excitement?
Were there anyone-- were
there any camps that weren't
interested in [INAUDIBLE]?
KEYON DOOLING:
Yeah, well, look I
didn't start this discussion
about mental health.
I helped contribute
to it, so I don't
want to take all the credit.
I don't want to take
all that credit.
But I think that the stigma is
changing, slowly but surely.
I think six years ago
when I had my breakdown,
I think it was a
negative perception
around mental health.
And I think I wasn't able to get
another job because of that--
because of the negative
stigmas associated with that.
There wasn't a lot of people
talking about mental health.
There wasn't a lot
of people who really
were trying to dive into it.
But I think as a
country, as a society,
I think we're in a
place right now where
we're ready to have
these discussions.
And I think so many
brave people are-- have
been telling their stories.
And as athletes, we have a lot
of visibility, a lot of fame.
We also have resources to
be able to get behind things
that we're passionate about.
And I'm so encouraged that
these guys are starting
to share their stories.
Because there are some really--
people see the glory, but
they don't see the story.
And it's so many
stories that guys
have to overcome that help
them to be as excellent as they
are on the court.
And so I'm just glad to
be a part of the dialogue.
I think the timing is right.
And I'm just happy that DeMar
and Kevin Love and the NBA
Players Association has
given us this platform
to be empowered
about mental health.
MJ: So obviously there
are a lot of players
who are open about it, but
around the league are--
do you think that
players will be
receptive of actually accessing
this type of treatment?
KEYON DOOLING: Oh, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I think our guys, man, are
ready to get to the next level.
I think like I said, we
have the best trainers.
We have the best coaches.
We've got the--
we're very visible.
But also there's
a personal growth
that I think our guys
are ready to pursue.
You're starting to see
them get more educated.
We're starting to see them
get more business oriented.
But now you're starting to see
the emotional maturity and guys
really trying to get
better as people, deal
with their issues
in a positive way,
make sure that
they're not masking
their pain in a
negative way but they're
dealing with their
pain in a positive way.
And so I think that's going
to translate to society.
As athletes, I think they
have a great platform.
They have fans who follow
them and appreciate them.
And so if they become more
awake about their mental health
and more aware about
their mental health,
I think that can translate
into all these great fans who
follow us.
MJ: Yeah, that's a great
point and speaks to the power
that a lot of NBA
athletes have just
using their platform for
these positive messages.
When you think about the
evolution of this program
and of the state of
mental health in the NBA,
what do you see success
looking like in five years?
If we sat down here
in May of 2023,
what story do you want to
be telling about the NBA?
KEYON DOOLING: I want
people to say that, hey, you
know those guys that
lead the NBA, they really
normalize mental health.
They de-stigmatize
mental health.
They treated a
mental health issue
the same way and with the
same love and care that they
treated a physical injury.
And if they can do it in the
NBA, they can do it at Google.
If they do it-- if they
can do it at Google,
they can do it in the
police department.
If they can do it in
the police department,
they can do it in
the teacher's union.
And it could almost infect
our country in a positive way.
If we start having these normal
talks about mental health,
man, people can really
get their healing.
I'm telling you, healing--
I never thought I could heal
from some of the things that I
went through-- being abused as
a child, growing up in poverty,
seeing a--
I saw my first gunfight
at 11 years old.
I saw a gun shootout
And I just never
knew that I could
be this happy and this
healthy emotionally
without having to get loaded.
Straight up.
And so I'm just so excited to
be a part of this dialogue.
I'm happy that I was
vulnerable enough
six years ago to share my story
because if I hadn't got out
in front of it, I wouldn't
even have this platform.
And a lot of times when
you're funding your purpose
and you're finding
your mission, it
might not be pretty, the thing
that you have to overcome.
Some people grapple
with addiction.
with gambling.
Some people grapple with all
kinds of different things.
And I found so much power in
overcoming my shortcomings.
It's really helped me as a man.
MJ: Yes, absolutely.
I'm just going to ask a
couple of more questions,
then I'm going to open it up
to questions live in the room,
and also we have some online.
Obviously your work
is very focused
on de-stigmatizing mental
health, and a lot of people
unfortunately are still
suffering silently.
So if there were someone who
is watching or in the room who
is suffering silently right
now, what would you say to them?
What would your
piece of advice be?
KEYON DOOLING: Well, so the
first thing-- look, I've
been there.
I've suffered in silence.
I didn't talk about
my sexual abuse
until I had a major
breakdown, and I
was 32 years old at the time.
And so 25 years, I
suffered in silence.
So the first thing I would
say is I understand that.
And the next thing
I would say is
I wish I would have
done my work earlier.
The hardest part about healing
is taking that first step.
And I know I've--
I'm echoing that
message, but it's so hard
to set that appointment
to go see that therapist.
It's just like,
oh, I'm not crazy.
Oh, what if people going
to think I'm crazy.
Man, I got so much
healing in doing that.
So the first thing is embrace
the pain, embrace the hurt.
The second thing
is find examples
of success stories
of people who might
have overcome an issue that
you might be struggling with.
The next thing I would
say is go to therapy.
Go get your help.
If you have an issue
with your body,
I know you go get
that checked out.
So it's the same
thing if your heart,
if your head, if your
emotions are out of whack,
go to therapy.
Last thing I would say
is activate your network.
A lot of times we don't know
how much our network loves us.
And a lot of times,
we don't allow
people to be friends
or be relatives to us.
When we're going
through something,
we say I'll take care
of this by myself.
Don't self-care when
it's about mental health.
Get people involved who love
you who you trust so that they
can support you because I
couldn't be as healthy as I
am without my support system.
And so if I'm having an off
day and my anxiety is up,
like, babe, my anxiety
is up a little bit today.
I just want to share
that with you so you
can help me through that.
And there's things
that the people
who love they'll do for
you that really helps you.
And so just don't
think you're alone.
That's the last thing.
Don't think you're alone.
Because when we're
alone, we isolate.
That's when our mind
can get to racing.
That's when those negative
behaviors can come out.
So just remember
you're not alone
if you're going through it.
MJ: And-- absolutely.
And if you aren't suffering,
sometimes the most powerful
thing that you can do
is just lend an open ear
and ask someone
how are you today.
KEYON DOOLING: Absolutely.
MJ: Even if they
don't say anything,
just knowing that someone
is there supporting
you can make a big difference.
So everyone, ask the
person next to you
or when you're going to get
your lunch later today how
someone else is doing.
And we'll all be better off.
All right, I'm going
to move to questions.
Do we have any live in the room?
There's a microphone over
there if you want to go up.
We have livestream
so people can hear.
But in the meantime,
I'll ask one from online.
Dan in San Francisco-- hi, Dan--
Chris Bosh said that if
players like Kevin Love
continue to speak about
their mental health,
players will look to
exploit that info.
Have you talked with
Chris about this?
Is there currently
an on court culture
where mental health
should or should not
be the subject of trash talk.
Go Celtics.
I think Dan's a Celtics fan.
And I'm pretty sure he is
wearing a Celtics jersey
and wishes he could be here.
KEYON DOOLING: Right.
Right.
Well, I'm not sure what
Chris said, but as far
as mental health, I don't
think your mental health
can be exploited no different
from your physical health or--
when you go on the
court, you're focused.
You're ready to play.
But everybody is
grappling with something.
See we have these negative
stereotypes about mental health
that it's like schizophrenia
or it's paranoia.
And it's not.
Sometimes mental
health is very subtle.
It might be through anxiety.
It might be through-- there's
30,000 people in here looking
at me, and I might get stage
fright or something like that.
That's not a negative thing.
It's just a human-- it's a
part of the human experience.
And so I would say
that I don't think
you can be exploited for your
mental health on the basketball
court.
When guys are on the
court-- trust me--
if you're on the court in
the NBA, you are locked in
and you are focused on your
job, your role on the team,
and trying to win a basketball
game and support your family.
You're not really thinking
about, hey, how can I get under
this guy's skin to
make him explode.
I think there's a
healthy level of respect
we have for NBA players
amongst one another.
We respect each other's craft.
And I don't think anybody
would try and exploit
if somebody is going to
do something emotionally.
MJ: Absolutely.
Although Chris Paul did
shimmy in Steph Curry's face
the other day.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah, well,
that's not an emotional attack.
MJ: That was just
an automatic reflex.
KEYON DOOLING: That's
just competition.
MJ: That's being locked in?
KEYON DOOLING: That's right.
MJ: We have a live question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
This is related to
the previous question.
But do you think
there's anything
about playing in the NBA that
makes it harder for those
with mental health
issues, for example, I
guess the constant
media pressure,
maybe if you miss a
free throw, everyone
labels you as a choker.
It's this drive that
you have to win.
Otherwise, it's like
this failure of a season.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah,
man, great question.
I think NBA players and
professional athletes and not
just professional athletes.
I would say high achievers
to much is given,
much is required.
I think we experience
more than others.
A lot of times, we're young.
We're from impoverished
communities.
And we're thrusted into the
patriarch of the family.
That's a struggle in itself.
I think a lot of
times we're judged
on how much we weigh, how
we look, our appearance,
and so that's always
tough to deal with.
Now we have social media.
So you can hear all--
you can go on your phone
and see all these negative
comments about yourself,
or you could be
having a meal and get
a phone flashed in your face.
So, yeah, I do think
that high achievers,
in particular famous
people, have more
to deal with than
the average person.
I enjoy not being famous
more than I enjoy fame.
I get so much more
peace of mind--
so much-- such-- a
much easier experience.
Fame is a very tough thing to
deal with and not only fame.
Fame, you compound that
with money and youth, that's
a very dangerous antidote.
So thanks for that question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MJ: Kind of going off that,
you mentioned youth and money
and being thrown
into the spotlight.
Do you think there's anything
specific to rookies or younger
players that the
NBA could be doing--
in our education
system, for example,
we're not really taught
about a lot of the skills
that we need to succeed,
especially in those situations.
KEYON DOOLING: Right.
MJ: Are there plans to
introduce any type of education
or mentoring program.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah, well,
we have several programs.
I think that-- well, I'll
speak for the NBA Players
Association.
I think we do about
40 different programs.
We have everything
from broadcast
to leadership, which is
training for if you want
to go into the front office.
We have a transition
program that's
helping guys in
their transition.
We just started the
mental health program.
We have career development.
We have the programming.
The programming and the
infrastructure is in place.
The key is to make sure that the
guys get it while they're still
in the game.
That's the key.
A lot of times guys wait 'til--
it's the end of their career
to try and start building
themselves up and preparing
for the next phase of life.
And I think if we can get them
to start developing themselves
earlier, I think that transition
will be a lot more smooth.
MJ: Well, you're on top of that.
You want another live question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here today.
So going back to the
work of your foundation,
you talked about working with
children and I'm a new mom.
And so I was wondering what are
techniques that you use maybe
even with your own family or
with the children to promote
and create and foster
an environment so
that your children feel like
you're taking care of them?
KEYON DOOLING: Oh!
Thank you for asking.
I had to lean in on that
one because, man, it's
all about the kids, man.
And I think we can stop this
vicious cycle on their watch.
I would say the
first thing is that I
think we make conversations
around our bodies too hard.
And I would say normalizing
that conversation--
when I talk to my kids
about their bodies,
their private parts,
I tell them, hey,
this is your private part.
This is your body.
Daddy, shouldn't
touch you there.
Mommy, shouldn't
This is your body.
And if anybody ever
touches you in that way,
you have to let me know so
that mommy and daddy can
protect you.
Conversations, hey, this
is healthy conversations.
Don't let anybody talk
to you about your body
or if somebody says
something that's offensive
or cursing or something
like that, baby,
you can always talk to me.
I think it's just really
about communicating.
And then also watching
because a lot of times
when a kid is going
through something,
you'll see some
behavioral changes,
whether they're aggressive
or whether they're aloof
and just being in tune with your
kids, asking them questions.
How are you doing,
looking at their bodies
from time to time making
sure that-- oh, you
got a bruise on your leg.
Oh, you know mama
see everything.
Come on let's put
some Neosporin on it
or whatever the case may be.
But just really
you know empowering
them to be able to
communicate with you.
The worst thing that I
did was internalize it
at seven years old.
See I ran the tape in my head.
I couldn't tell my
dad because I didn't
know what he would do
like would he go back
and he would get revenge?
I couldn't tell my mom because
I just didn't know how to.
I couldn't share
with my siblings
because I didn't
think anything of me.
I couldn't tell my friends
because I didn't want them
to think my manhood was gone.
And so I decided
to internalize it.
And that wasn't the
healthy way to do it.
I could have lost my life
by internalizing that.
And so thank you for
asking that question.
I think it's very healthy to
communicate with your kids
in an honest way.
And don't sugarcoat it
because the world is
a very cruel place,
and the people
who are out there
being predators,
they are aggressive to
try and get it done.
And so I think we have to be
just as aggressive or proactive
against their aggression
towards our kids.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank
you for asking.
MJ: Great.
Another live question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You touched on some of this a
bit, but like playing sports
and especially at the
professional level
can definitely cause mental
challenges, whether it's
the fame or your paycheck
relies on how well you play.
And you said the NBA had
some programming available,
but I was wondering
if the NBA as a whole
or any specific teams
proactively reached out
to the players and said
these are some challenges you
might be facing.
Here are good ways
to deal with it.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah.
Yeah.
Good question.
I think each team has
resources in place and has--
some teams might
be further ahead
in their development of programs
around helping guys and others.
But I would say our league
has great resources.
We have-- I believe every
team now has a mental health
specialist that they work with.
I believe every team also
has a player development
coordinator who can
be a liaison to help
them get to all the resources.
The infrastructure
is great in the NBA.
It's just a matter of
it's hard to do your work
and develop yourself when
you're trying to be excellent
and trying to earn
in this short window.
But I think this
generation is changing.
I see that these Millennials
are so much stronger
than we give them credit for.
They speak their truth.
They are very talented,
a little entitled,
but I think this
generation is bold.
And I'm so proud
of this generation.
And I look forward to
helping transfer information
from one generation
to the next so
that they don't have to start
all over with doing their work.
So they can build off of this
discussion about mental health
and not have to start
from ground level
because I believe
that in 10 years,
mental health will be
so normal that I believe
like a great part of people
will just be advocates for it.
It'll be normal the same way
getting physical therapy is.
Thanks for the question.
Thank you.
I love these questions.
Thank you for asking questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you for
the very open discussion.
I really appreciate it.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Back to
the topic about kids,
does the Respect Foundation have
any sort of therapy programs
for let's say like if
you were seven years old,
you had no one to reach out to.
But if there had been like
some kind of therapy program
that maybe you could have
reached out to as a kid,
maybe you wouldn't have
had to internalize it
when you had no one else to
turn to because of the stigma
of what you went through
and the shame that you
felt even though it wasn't
your fault. That happens.
But can you just speak to that
like therapy programs for kids.
KEYON DOOLING: Yeah, so
our main program right now
is called the I Am Respect Tour.
And like I said earlier, we
bring music, entertainment,
spoken word, a DJ, but the
content that we deliver
is very conscious.
And it's around mental
health and sexual abuse
and how to prevent it.
I'm not a therapist, so I
can't do that work myself.
I'm a life coach, so we
have grown and evolved
to that point where we
can send kids to therapy.
But what we do is we
raise awareness around it.
We've touched probably about
10,000 kids in the last four
years, and in doing that, we
connect them with the resources
that they do have access to.
And so if you have
access in the community,
we usually partner
with an organization
that has great
infrastructure resources,
but we don't provide
the resources ourselves.
We use our network to
be able to help people.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
Thank you.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
MJ: And we have another question
from online again from Dan.
Big fan.
The Kawhi Leonard
injury has shown us
that when the team
and players seek
different medical opinions,
drama and disagreement
can occur.
How do you anticipate
handling similar situations
involving mental health?
What if a player's
therapist disagrees
with the team psychologist
about his ability to play?
KEYON DOOLING: Ooh,
that's a good one.
And I think we had--
we've been dealing with
that issue around the NBA
for quite some time.
There was a high-profile
case of a draft
pick probably about
five or six years ago
who had a phobia around flying.
And so I'm sure
that there's going
to be a learning curve as we try
and get this system worked out.
But I believe the hearts and the
minds are in the right place.
I think we're still learning
about mental health.
And so I don't have a definite
answer to that right now,
but I do believe that that's
something that will come up
at some point or another.
And there's going
to be people who
are higher pedigree than me who
will be able to handle that.
MJ: Well, it's
comforting to know
that you'll be in
the conversation
because you are definitely--
your head and heart are
definitely in the right place.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
MJ: Another one,
Becky in San Francisco
asks what is the best way to
support a friend or family
member who has suffered
from childhood abuse?
KEYON DOOLING: Becky,
I'm so sorry your family
member or your friend
had to endure that.
I've been there so
I know how that is.
The thing about abuse is not
only does it hurt the victim
but it hurts the infrastructure
around the victim
because there is a
certain guilt that might
be associated with the parents.
Oh, maybe I didn't protect it.
Oh, what could I have
done differently?
There are siblings who
like, man, I would have
rammed through a wall for you.
I couldn't protect you.
I would say the most
important thing that you do
is love them, love on them.
Let them know that it's OK.
Try and help them
get to the resources
because you have
to do your work.
If you don't do your
work, you really
open yourself up to these
behaviors, these behaviors that
could be very, very
detrimental to your health.
And so the first
thing love on them.
Let them know-- support them.
Help them get to the resources.
Let them know that
you understand.
Sometimes you don't
have to say anything.
Sometimes you've just got
to be there and just smile.
Let them know you're--
hey, I'm here for you
whenever you want to talk.
Do preventative things.
Go and check on them.
Spend some time
with that person.
Maybe go to a group
session with them.
I think that is also good when
your support system supports
you in those group sessions.
That's helpful as
well but just knowing
that they trust you to
be able to talk about it,
just continuously check
in with them, make sure
that they're OK because a lot of
times flashbacks can come back.
You can smell something that
might take you back to a place.
You could see something that
might take you to a place.
You can hear something that
could take you back to a place.
And those flashbacks are real.
And a part of my PTSD when
the abuse was coming back,
I was trying to push it down,
and that confliction I believe
is where my mind
really start to race.
And that's a
dangerous place to be.
So just making sure that
they have the resources
and they feel
supported is important.
MJ: None of us have
all the answers,
but it's important just to show
up for our friends and family.
We are at the hour,
so we'll end here.
But I do have one
burning question for you.
KEYON DOOLING: Okey doke.
MJ: Who do you think is going
to win tonight, Celtics or Cavs?
KEYON DOOLING: So
I'm a Celtics fan.
I played for the Celtics.
That's the organization
that helped save my life,
but I believe the Celtics
are on the road tonight.
And the home team has won
every game in this series,
and so I will say tonight I
believe the Cavs will get them.
MJ: All right, well--
AUDIENCE: What about tomorrow?
MJ: What about tomorrow?
Live question.
KEYON DOOLING: I'm sorry.
I couldn't hear that.
MJ: Warriors Versus Rockets?
[LAUGHS]
KEYON DOOLING: No, I
believe the home team will
win that game as well tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MJ: All right, seven
game series all the way.
Well, Keyon, thank you
so much for sharing
your story, all the
work that you're doing,
and coming here today.
You have so much going on.
We are so appreciative of you
spending your time with us.
KEYON DOOLING: No problem.
MJ: So thank you.
And I'm excited to see
everything else you do.
KEYON DOOLING: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, MJ.
Great job.
MJ: You also.